اليابان حيث اقر تاع الحكومه اليابانيه
مراجعه جذريه
لسياساتها الدفاعيه في محاوله للتصدي
للنفوذ العسكري الصيني الذي وصفته طوكيو
بانه تحدي استراتيجيا غير مسبوق لانها
القوي اليابان اعلنت في اطار اكبر مراجعه
سياستها الدفاعيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه مضاعفه ميزانيه الدفاع السنويه
الى اكثر من 80 مليار دولار اي اثنين في
المئه من الناتج المحليه الاجمالي في غضون
خمس سنوات كما قرر توحيد قيادتها العسكريه
وزياده مدى صواريخها ما يجعل الميزانيه
العسكريه اليابانيه هي الثالثه في العالم
بعد الولايات المتحده والصين
ما الذي تتضمنه والاسرجي الدفاعيه الجديده
التي اقرها مجلس الوزراء اليمني تعتبر
روسيا مصدر قلق للامن القومي هذا في
الاساس ولكن تعتبر ايضا الصين تحدي
الاستراتيجيا غير مسبوق وتتضمن التعديلات
الجديده حق القوات اليابانيه في سن ضربات
مضاده ضد دول تعتبرها معاديه الضربات
المضاده تستلزم تحقيق ثلاثه شروط وهي
تهديد حتمي لليابان او لدوله صديقه يقود
لتهديد الحتميه لليابان والا توجد وسيله
اخرى لتفادي الضربات التي تعتبر معاديه
وان يكون الرد بالحد الادنى الممكن اذا
هذه هي الشروط التعديلات تنص على مضاعفه
ميزانيه الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس
المقبله وان يكون الدفاع المحور الاساسي
لتعزيز القوه العسكريه ولا يكون الهدف
ابدا ان تصبح اليابان دوله عسكريه حيث
ستتم ضعفه ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع خلال
السنوات الخمس القادمه لتصبح نحو 50 مليار
دولار سنويا ما يضع اليابان في المرتبه
الثالثه بين اكبر الميزانيه العسكريه بعد
الولايات المتحده والصين